بعد يوم واحد من الهجوم الذي استهدف قلعه
القرار ورمز السلطه في موسكو تمضي روسيا
في حديثها عن الرد غير عابئه بالانكار
الاوكراني تتحدث روسيا عن خيارات متعدده
للرد لا تفصح عن تفاصيلها لكنها تتواعد
بان الرد سيكون مدروسا ومتوازنا وانما
وصفته بالعقاب ات لا محاله وسيكون صارما
يصف الكرملين في بيان انكار واشنطن
مسؤوليتهما عن الهجوم بالسخيف ويوزع
البيان المهام حيث اتهم واشنطن بالتخطيط
للعمليه في حين قال ان مهمه كييف كانت
التنفيذ فقط اتهامات رد عليها منسق
الاتصالات بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
حيث قال جون كاربي ان واشنطن لا تشجع
اوكرانيا ولا تمكنها من المعدات التي تسمح
لها بتوجيه ضربات خارج اراضيها وقال ان
المزاعم الروسيه كاذبه اما اوكرانيا التي
نفت بدورها علاقتها بالهجوم فاكدت ان
اولوياتها تحري ر اراضيها وليس الهجوم على
موسكو وتحدث رئيسها
في زيارته عن الاف الجرائم التي قال ان
روسيا ارتكبتها في شهر واحد
اما على الجبهات فيوميات الحرب تكتب
باستمرار دون تسجيل الغلبه لاي من
الفريقين حتى الان ما تزال باخمت محور
الصراع منذ اشهر عصيه على الروس لاشهر
متتاليه رغم تقدمهم في محاور عده وسط تمسك
الجيش الاوكراني بمواقعه غرب المدينه
ويتحدث الجيش الاوكراني عن اسقاط 18 طائره
مسيره ايرانيه من طراز شاهد من اصل 24
اطلقتها القوات الروسيه من بحر ازوف جنوبا
باتجاه مدن الجنوب والعاصمه وفي المنطقه
الحدوديه قال حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت مسيره اوكرانيه
كانت تعتزم مهاجمه المقاطعه وفيزا بروجيا
تتحدث المصادر العسكريه الروسيه عن
استهداف مخازن ذخيره وتجمع لاليات الجيش
الاوكراني كما استهدف الروس ايضا مستودعا
اوكرانيا اخر للذخيره قرب مدينه بيرسلاف
في مقاطعه خرسون خرسون التي تحاول ان
تلملم جراحها بعد قصف روسي اسفر عن مقتل
50 شخصا ويسارع سكان الخطى لجمع الماونه
وتخزينها تحسبا لهجوم روسي يقولون انه
وشيك وعنيف